what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to um
little little tom tim off the list
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
about the way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
all right let's let's get this party
started
[Music]
okay
hey money's talking this [ __ ] hard bruh
[Music]
okay so he's letting you know that
he killed somebody he's a killer
so he said i have a list of people i'm
knocking off the list so he's killing
people one by one
[ __ ] it was me but tim this little lick
then we thought we're packing for half a
brick posted on the three i gotta know
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] spit lol forgive me for my
sins
putting all these [ __ ] off of god the
way they've been okay
so he's asking god for forgiveness he's
saying i'm so sorry
that i killed these people forgive me
[Music]
okay so he said a couple things one
he's saying that he will spin again even
if he misses which is contradictory okay
to his first statement saying he doesn't
miss but now he's saying if i miss
i'ma come back and go again which is a
little bit contradictory for like
asking god for forgiveness because if
you're going to ask god for
forgiveness and then be like i'd do it
again
i don't know how he's going to take that
but you know i'm going to just press
play
[Music]
[Music]
know we screaming murder in my time we
do it [ __ ]
yeah we like that song we split this wig
yup black forces all black you know
don't dicky face
okay i i just want to go back for a
second look at these dance moves
i mean like what are one of these all
black you know
like picky face like you see that guy
he's like
tell me you want some smoke so we
smoking like a sick boy you [ __ ] as a
[ __ ]
again bad [ __ ] [ __ ] is that a squirt
do you think they coordinated the
outfits on purpose i think they did
you know i love matching guys up on the
list i'll be sneaking
[Music]
okay well you know that's an interesting
interesting video we got going on there
uh i'm gonna give that a two out of five
because quite honestly
i wasn't shimmying like normally i'll
give a little shimmy if i like it and i
just
i wasn't shimmy also there's a lot of
contradictions in the song
like asking god for forgiveness and
saying i'd do it again
so that's just my two cents but let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell i will talk to you guys next time